somebody once said that the chains of
heaven are too light to be felt until
about too heavy to be broken successful
people aren't fearless they're scared to
take action just like you are the more
scared we are of a work or calling the
more sure we can be that we have to do
it rise and shine it's an espresso time
what's up believe nation it's Evan I
believe in you and this channel is
designed to be a part of your daily
success routine so let's start your day
off right together grab your coffee and
sip on today's message conquer your
fears over to you Warren Buffett also if
you want to know at war and other
successful entrepreneurs have to say
about building unstoppable confidence
check out my 250 for confidence series
where every day for the next 254 days I
will send you a morning video for free
to help you build your confidence the
link to join is in the description below
it's important to associate with people
that are better than yourself somebody
once said that the chains of heaven are
too light to be felt until they're too
heavy to be broken I have been terrified
of public speaking I couldn't do it man
throw up
and I know if I didn't cure it then they
never cured and so I saw an ad in the
paper for the Dale Carnegie horse which
worked on developing your ability to
speak in public and I went down there
a good thing the thing at the puppies
video they made us do all these crazy
things to get out of ourselves and so we
stood on tables and did all kinds of
things
[Music]
if I hadn't have done that my whole life
would have been different
so in my office you will not see the
degree I got from the University of
Nebraska they'll not see the master's
degree I got from Columbia University
but you'll see the World War certificate
I got from the Dale Carnegie course
successful people aren't fearless
they're scared to take action just like
you are the difference between
successful people and everyone else is
they feel the fear and they do it anyway
they don't allow the fear to control
them this is one of the most important
skills you can ever learn whatever fear
is in front of you as long as you give
it power and control over you you will
never accomplish your goals you'll be
here in the exact same spot that you are
right now one year from today facing the
exact same fear wondering why you
haven't grown facing your fear is scary
it's supposed to be but it's the only
way to not let that fear have control
over your life anymore and it's the only
way you're actually going to achieve
that big dream of yours so if you're
ready to face your fear instead of
letting it control your life give me and
I'm ready in the comments below now my
biggest fear is in disappointing people
I hate the idea of letting somebody down
I hate the idea of that somebody will
come and see me or book a time with me
or I'm gonna go meet with somebody and
they leave feeling like they wasted
their time and so as a result I end up
always over delivering I'm always early
to show up the meetings I'm always over
prepared I put in a lot of work because
I hate the idea of disappointing people
and so when my agent suggested that I do
this tour this 23 city tour over 90 days
and he said that I should charge for it
I did not want
do it I did not want to charge for it
even though it made sense because when I
did coffee-shop meetups we had too many
people showing up and it was not a great
experience of people and they couldn't
hear me and I couldn't get to everybody
and I wasn't giving the value that I
could be giving I didn't like the idea
of charging for it because I felt like I
would be disappointing some people
because I still remember being that
entrepreneur who was making 300 bucks a
month and the idea of spending 45
dollars on something would have been
crazy and so because I was afraid of
doing it though I had to go off and do
it because I'm afraid of letting
somebody down but it makes sense for my
business of where I need to take my
mission then I have to do it when you
feel the fear that's the most important
thing it's not I'm afraid and so I'm
going to tell myself some story as to
why I can't do it it's know I'm afraid
and it's a legit fear you're right
I am afraid and so now what are you
gonna do when you get confronted with
the fear what do you do this is a really
important moment because if you then
decide that I'm gonna play small because
I'm afraid of that thing then you're
teaching yourself I'm the kind of person
who will constantly play small but if
you feel the fear and then you jump into
and say I don't know if it's gonna work
out I'm afraid but I'm gonna do it
anyway that's when you start to build
confidence that's when you start to
build momentum into your business that's
when you start to release the control
that that fear has over you and so doing
the 23 city tour for me is scary right
I'm worried that I won't be able to
deliver value I'm worried that people be
disappointed I'm worried that some
people think that it was a ripoff for
them and because I'm so worried about
that because I hate disappointing people
so much it means I'm gonna bring so much
incredible value to each of the events
it means I'm gonna weigh over deliver
like crazy to make sure that everybody
leaves there having had a tremendous
experience it's so important for me that
the people who come out that this event
in whatever city they're going to is the
next turning point for them I'm putting
that much pressure myself that for this
forty five dollar ticket this will be
your next turning point I have to bring
that level value for me to be happy
whatever you are expecting my own
expectations are way above it this needs
to be the most life-changing event for
you in 2019 that's what I believe and so
by jumping into that fear I grow
stronger and by jumping into whatever
fear you have you'll go stronger too
okay so how do you do it you know how do
you jump into fear it's great to say
well go off and do it but how do you
train yourself what do you tell yourself
how do you get your mind set to the
point where oh my gosh is this crazy
thing in front of me how do I move into
it instead of running away I'm gonna
give you a three-step process to help
step number one is the rocking chair
test this is where you imagine your life
at the end of your life you know how
over old you're gonna be you might be
200 years old by the time we get there
but when you're at your end of your life
you're about to die and you're living
out your last days the rocking chair
tests look back on this moment and this
is what I do
I don't want to live with regret and we
very rarely regret the things that we
did it's most often the actions not
taken you will regret the stuff that you
do not do because you are afraid if you
do not do this thing that's in front of
you because you're afraid you will
regret that for the rest of your life
and what I do is I make that future
regret so painful I make it so
incredible I imagine decades if I didn't
agree to do the tour I would imagine
decades like this would have been the
greatest moment in my life like this
would have been the turning point and I
was too afraid to jump in and do it and
the decades and decades of suffering
that I would have as a result and then I
bring that back to the present moment
and then realize that that future pain
is so much bigger than the current pain
of just going off and doing the thing
and so imagine that this thing is in
front of you if you don't do it you will
regret it forever and make that moment
so painful that it forces you into
action right now use the rocking chair
test number two is remember that you
rock you've had some moments of success
you've had moments of victory in the
past you know that you can do this thing
you may not always believe it but you
have had moments where you rock and so I
go through this phase even right now as
I'm preparing for my tour I go through
these moments where I'll think about
holy cow got this tour coming up I need
to I need to provide insane value I need
to prepare more I need to have every
line down and I need to I need to crush
it because people are paying to come and
see me and it better be the greatest
thing of all time for them and then I
look at my notes of what I've done for
for my plans for what the workshops are
gonna be like and I look it over like
holy cow this content is amazing if I
deliver it what I wrote down it's gonna
be life-changing for people who come out
and I remind myself that this is amazing
like that I rock that I crush when I get
into it that meeting people face-to-face
and experience any energy is so much
better than just seeing me on camera
here like when people interact with me
the energy transfer is real you will
come out believing in yourself more and
so reminding myself that I rock that I'm
great at this stuff that this is
actually the thing that fills me up the
most that this is what allows me to have
the most impact on people helps me get
through and so you to remember that you
rock remember that you're awesome
remember that you help people remember
that you're good at this thing remember
that you're gonna get a result out of it
remember that if you keep putting in the
effort and the work and the hustle you
will get the result that you're after
remember remind yourself whatever that
process is if you think back to past
victories if you think back to awards
you've gotten if you think back to the
customers that you've helped remind
yourself that you rock and that you can
do this and step three is tie yourself
worth to the effort not the results this
becomes super important because at the
beginning of anything you will have
setbacks you won't win out of the gate
it'll be slow you'll get tiny little
miniscule results and then if you keep
putting in the effort and you keep
working hard you will get better it may
take a long time depending on how gifted
you are and how quickly you learn but if
you can tie your self-respect
to the effort that you put in you will
ultimately win this is what successful
people do it's great to win successful
people win all the time but they've lost
way more than they've won and the people
who end up being losers in life they
don't even try because they're afraid of
the loss because all you want to do is
win and you're too afraid to lose and so
you don't even try and that's the
biggest loss of all and so if you can
detach yourself from the result and say
at the beginning I expect to suck at the
beginning I don't think this is gonna
work out that your first YouTube video
won't get any comments that your first
Instagram posts won't be very good that
the first time I get in front of the
camera you will be terrible and nervous
and not know how to get words out of
your mouth that the first time you go
and do a sales presentation they're not
gonna say yes I expect to suck at the
beginning of everything that I do and
then that relieves the pressure because
I expect my first thing to suck and then
I'll keep getting better the more I do
it the more practice I put in and so if
you can tie your self-respect how you
value yourself the opinion that you have
of your
Souths - how much effort you're putting
in and are you getting better than you
were yesterday as opposed to just
looking at the results that's where you
ultimately will win five years ago I had
seven thousand subscribers on my youtube
channel I started putting out three
videos a day I started getting better I
was cringing looking at my own content I
couldn't watch my own videos back but I
did three videos a day for five years
and I got better and I still have a long
way to go on my journey but I'm getting
better and I'm getting better and I'm
getting better and I tie my self-worth
why I love myself so much is because of
the effort that I put in much more than
any specific result much more than the
play buttons that I get for hitting
certain milestones it's the effort that
I'm putting in that I love myself for
and I want that for you too so one use
the rocking chair test to remember that
you rock and three tie yourself respect
and self-esteem to your effort not the
results now I've got a really special
bonus good for you that I think you're
gonna enjoy but before that question of
the day I want to know what is the fear
that you're ready to face right now put
it down in the comments below
you know it seems like we can't open a
book or read a blog post these days
without hearing somebody tell you to
follow your passion or follow your bliss
or follow your heart and yes I have said
those things too but today I want to
talk about the power of going in what
can often feel like the opposite
direction I want to talk about the power
of following your fear I'm not talking
about following your very useful fear of
big moving vehicles and walking in front
of a bus nor am i talking about doing
anything stupid or irresponsible that
could ruin you financially what I am
talking about though is the power of
following good fear directive fear the
kind of fear that you feel when you have
an idea that just won't leave you alone
an idea about doing something that
you've always wanted to do something
that's different and bold and kind of
risky where part of you saying oh no I
actually couldn't do that but the deeper
wiser part of you wants this thing so
damn bad and the moment you imagine
yourself going for it you have worries
like you know will people laugh at me
will they ignore me maybe this isn't
even really an idea what if I do it and
it sucks
am I gonna destroy my reputation am I
gonna lose my marriage and my family and
wind up living on the streets my friend
Steven Pressfield talks about this kind
of fear in the war of art and he says
remember our rule of thumb the more
scared we are of a work or calling the
more sure we can be that we have to do
it and he continues the more fear we
feel about a specific enterprise the
more certain we can be that that
enterprise is important to us and the
growth of our soul Cheryl says what is
Gaby's biggest fear good
question you know I think that I think
that I don't even want to say them out
loud yeah how about that cool I see you
fighting me yeah because I don't want to
bring energy to it yeah sure I like that
cannot spend on that [ __ ] well here's
the joke so we all have fears you know
no matter how committed to love we are
no matter how deeply deeply connected we
are to our own our own spiritual
practice and to God into the universe we
will always have fear you know unless we
somehow become enlightened which is
possible but we will live with fear and
it's it's it's not that the fear goes
away completely as the spiritual student
it's just that you don't believe in it
anymore so when you ask me to share my
fears
it's like talking about something that
it's like not true for me so of course
there's fear and they pop up and they're
you know it's a present but it's not
real for me so it feels like like I'm
doing the world a disservice to say it
out loud if you want more Warren Buffett
check out the top ten rules video made
on him the link is right there next to
me I think you'll enjoy it continue to
believe and I'll see you there defining
your circle of competence is the most
important aspect of investing